yeah it's like it was easier for me to
go in the test for undateable when I was
a PA nobody wanted yeah that was easier
for me because I was excited about that
I was going because they know me yeah he
was a be a for Conan yeah Conan O'Brien
and Conan O'Brien
you were PA for how long before that
show three years of Conan in the whole
run in The Tonight Show with Conan Wow
Wow how long is that I was like almost
four years and I was doing stand-up
every night
and so when coat when you booked
undateable the Conan's anything oh yeah
right I did yeah I did Conan after I
used to fill his car with gas and then
like six months later I have a parking
spot on the same lot on the stage next
to him and I used to go mr. O'Brien I
always called a mr. O'Brien he would
call me murderer they never got you and
then he would like [ __ ] with my car
like I remember PA I'm season one came
to me and he goes um Conan O'Brien is
[ __ ] with your car goddamn you O'Brien
and outside never explained it ya know
Conan was nice cuz I went to the upfront
we found out we got picked up I go the
upfront and I get to my hotel room and
his assistant was a good friend of mine
who's amazing it was like Conan one
would like to have drinks with you
tonight you know come meet everybody for
drinks you know cuz they were like a
second family to me like everybody at
Conan was great and I get to my hotel
room and there's a bottle of Dom
Perignon with a letter from Conan about
congratulations full circle all that and
I was like it was one of those moments
where it's like whoa like the
daydreaming under the like this stands
when people cuz I used to friends would
be doing the show and I will be standing
off to the side with the cameraman going
[ __ ] I want that and then camera guys
are all New Yorkers [ __ ] with me call
me Hollywood they're like when you gotta
be out here yeah I said mark my words I
will be on this show this year and I
said that because I was just fed up mad
and I got in the car I went home and I
went that was really stupid whatever
[ __ ] do that and then about five
months later I'm on the show and I'm
looking at one of the guys that works on
the stage guys Paul and I go hey Paul he
goes what I go told you and then they
opened the curtain and I came out from
the hole
oh the little competitive thinks that
made me not nervous because then he
laughed and he goes don't eat [ __ ] you
know and I was like yeah any calm yeah
yeah and let me sit on the couch he goes
let him do his closer on the couch
because it would kill and I was like oh
oh she did stand out I did stand up my
first time and then he brought me over
to do my closer on the couch oh my god
and then after that I was a guest like
I've been a guest a couple times Wow
amazing
full circle what it is called what it
could when does that ever happen yeah
that was crazy that you're on a show and
a PA or whoever yeah you know me who's
who you know you hear a lot of people
talk there's a lot of Conan yes yeah and
turns me Kaling John Krasinski Johnny
polar Jack McBrayer Tina Fey had done
some sketches on there and in New York
office but like there's really like a
laundry list of famous people that were
interns at Conan I was like the only PA
I think that environment I don't know I
think it's just like out for PA there
was an intern that was my like intern
when I was stage via Tonight Show and he
ended up starring in Project X and he
was just like an ASU student and I get a
text from Rachel Rush she just went CIA
this is what I'm just trying to get in
at the Comedy Store
yeah because Oliver just says how much
she loved you and like loved work and we
do I'm Mike Oliver sign him he's doing
the Todd Phillips movie and I'm like you
know yeah he just blew by me is another
audible and it shows you what a good
dude that guy is Conan yeah Conan's
better because a lot of guys could like
because Emma Lisa something I mean you
talked to anybody
yeah that did rose and so Rosen's
writing staff toward the end was like
guys like Dave Tyree Allan Stevens
although the old comedy archives right
and it to me the vibe was always anti
what you just said really like don't
lock eyes with me really live on style
either hostile whoa that dude she was
very hostile I mean I know she's on the
ABC lineup come on Bobby
I mean
that's friggin those ambassador big back
it's hit throw it Roseanne show come on
are you trying to lose a job she's my
co-star she's great he just said under
his breath he thought about it I just
thought about it
that was bet she changed see
transformation and also I'm here's
what's yours here's another thing though
okay it's just that all I'm saying right
is is that this is what I heard from a
couple of dudes that used to work in
that situation yeah yeah right I'm not
saying there's a lot of reality or
that's the truth things like that it's
just the vibe that I got there is a time
where we're Conan you they would use
interns to stand in for certain sketches
and so Conan is doing this is like my
third year there he's doing something
with like the interns where he's going
up and talking to my god audience
members for later and none of them are
looking at him and he finally goes why
does nobody look at me in the eyes and
it's because they were all told like
since the New York days don't look mr.
O'Brien in the eyes don't engage him
don't do this and he called what whoever
started that yeah it was not Conan and
he called it out and he goes okay
everybody here you can look at me
that's ridiculous yeah when did that
start I knew that was happening because
people are just running in the walls she
that's a saving many of these old days
is is that there's another god person I
might even name the person yeah all
right that does the same exact thing
right yeah I knew it would destroy your
I know destroy me here by Christmas I
know another person that does the same
thing write the note don't look at me in
the eye yes and that's not just there's
a lot of people like that I'm not saying
all right and what i'm saying is that
conan isn't yeah he's not a you know
he's like hi good morning
what's up dude how are you yeah sure
Gustav II did I look at you in the eyes
today yeah there we go yeah well you're
good people you also said you wouldn't
welcome